[Music]
hello we're here today from key direct
uh programming a 2015
hyundai santa fe
using the forza 200 the free 315
megahertz key between 2013 to 2018 this
is a brand new aftermarket key you can
purchase it directly on our website
as you can see here it's the
frequency s315 we're gonna use the auto
km100 for the programming
so it does have a current working key
this is the brand new aftermarket we're
gonna program in
go to email programming
i'm gonna try to auto vent it
sometimes the author likes the vehicle
to be in on position in order to auto
detect it so i just put the ignition on
should be able to pick up the plan now
2017 santa fe sport
smart key
control unit
read password
46.
is
instrument is
there we go that's our password
go back
to the system
smart key programming
it says it will delete all existing keys
yes
turn the ignition off instrument cluster
is up that's good
okay let's remember the password
yes
okay
i'm gonna put in the original key in
first
programming succeed would you like the
next one yes
okay
for a number of cases too programming
succeed okay
you can see the new remote
the old remote
i'm just gonna take the old one out of
the car
just with the new remote
proximity function works
then remote no problem
[Music]
trunk button
pops the trunk
amazing
thank you for watching have a nice day